may I ask you a question
no uh that's is
it who would like to ask me a question
other than Bobby go ahead do you have a
question yeah I have one go ahead here's
my
question my my question is is this is
this just one question for the entire no
no no no there's a million things we
talk about but like I need to I want to
ease into you that sounded weird sounds
seual I would ease into it I don't I
don't think you need EAS it's wide open
let's
go let's go I would love something to
drink all right we have water there yeah
I can see that okay you don't like it no
what else you got you want liquor no oh
you do do you drink liquor I'll drink
some of this but not with lemon well you
know what it's pretty good try it I'll
try it all right it doesn't taste like a
coffee thing it tastes lemony all right
what is your question I know I can't be
your I know I can't be your number one
your favorite Korean no you're not I I
know I know I know I know question
answer I know that I won't I know I
can't there's nothing do not you're in
the top
30 I know dude that's rude I can't I
can't apply to being your top three
Koreans I know who your number one is
why can't I apply to be three what's the
application I don't know what the
application is but I'm sure there is one
uh yeah Daniel Kim oh yeah so that's
true so Ken would be one Daniel Kim two
who's in your three or third slot is
what I'm saying oh uh let's see well
um Again Korean there's yeah they have
to be Korean born in Korea excuse me
born in Korea or half Korean Daniel was
born there but uh Dr Ken wasn't no do
you know where he was born no Japan
exactly so why'd you even ask that
question uh because I because just like
has to be in Asia just like the Seahawks
thing yeah no I was born in Thailand
Okay do you speak no Chinese my dad was
in the military there's a military base
there what branch Army all right
tracking how long was he stationed there
for and what rank did he acheve four
four Sergeant four years okay until he
was um deported I mean um what he was
deported dude he was into war any my
point is war the Vietnam War dude what
are you talking about dude just you know
there's a lot of Vietnam War dude uh no
you'll never make
it not even top three no okay top 30
though you said Yeah there I leave some
spaces
open you know like at a restaurant where
you can't just give those tables to
right right a civilian you can't even
name me your third one so that's even
that's I don't know uh no I you know
that yeah the entire cast of
uh say it crazy oh squid
C oh the whole cast of squ the whole
cast of is so they all right those slots
are open all right you know what I I'll
tell you this Joel um you know I will
make it my life duty really yeah to
prove to you and to get into the top
three spot what do you think you have to
do uh well I'm going to memorize I'm
going to buy the Blu-ray of community
okay she just going to buy it yeah I'm
going to watch every single one all
right right I mean yeah okay um well
I'll tell you this Eric Olsen is in my
top five and you're not in my top 30 so
H as you notice I did not I did not ask
for it
and don't really
care uh I I but it's really fun to be in
this storage
room it's my garage G it's my garage
Joel no no it's really nice yeah yeah
thank you so much you have a lot of
stuff I do have a lot of toys and
knickknacks and whatnot you know but um
are any of your toys here uh you have
any like a that's your you get one shelf
no but you know what we do still share
the same t-shirt Shir s we have not been
able to split there there's something
that him and I have okay Ken does not
wear M War t-shirts he does not wear
made War T-shirt I love made War I do
too it's a great company but as we said
it is expensive but it is I think in a
life where we all wear t-shirts get a
free Costco
sweatshirt uh I think it's like you know
our parents wore like they always
wearing collar shirts and fancy things
but we're like we wear t-shirts all over
but here's another thing I noticed about
you gray jeans yeah yeah what John
Elliot right but are they raw denim uh
no they're not okay uh they're finnished
Den denim they're destroyed denim
they're destroyed yeah yeah but John
Elliott he's a he's they're they're
great he's from LA and he's a
skateboarder and makes I know and from
Top no not really oh but um from top to
bottom though I like your style and I've
always have really yeah from afar yeah
and another thing you've done for me can
I tell you another thing you've done for
me no but I'd like to okay it was kind
see when everything anything gets posed
to me as a question I have to always why
that that goes against because it's not
really a question Ah that's true can I
tell you something else n I'm
fine one more thing is that all right no
no no no we've we've reached our time
all right all right all right all right
I'm not going to do that again